[Applaudissements]
il faisait chaud ce week-end très chaud
près de 40 degrés en ile de france et
quand la canicule frappe les grandes
villes tout le monde cherche un coin
pour se rafraîchir
il faut croire que les parisiens
s'étaient passé le mot pour se retrouver
au parc aquatique aquaboulevard et 11
heures du matin une foule de franciliens
et francilienne en quête de fraîcheur ou
de bronzage face à bon des débordements
pdi du marron le complexe a été pris
d'assaut et la fréquence a littéralement
explosé
accueillons plus de 4000 personnes en
même temps la direction du parc de 7000
m² assure que la situation s'est plutôt
bien passé face à la situation ubuesque
sur les réseaux les internautes se sont
donné à coeur joie l'aquaboulevard ou la
fausse d'un concert de linyola quoi
vouloir c'est un bol de céréales ont
leur piscine bon des problèmes d'hygiène
racisme au tour sur le week-end
mouvementé dacquois boulevards à paris
alors on va voir les images dans un
instant alban scholly directeur des
opérations de la cob le bar est avec no
mercy est on à audrey qui a passé une
journée aquaboulevard va nous raconter
ça audrey je crois que guillaume est
très content il aurait voulu
il a envie d'aller à la piscine à vagues
on va revoir les images pour bien se
rendre compte du monde qu'il y avait
samedi à caen boulevard regardé l'avant
après c'est complètement fou rire
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est vrai qu'il y avait énormément
de monde c'était la folie alors on va
revoir plusieurs images qui dit beaucoup
de monde sur les régions a vu des images
de pédiluve de bassins remplis de monde
et c'est regarder parce que c'est vrai
que le pédiluve on a eu une explication
c'est parce que du sable en fait voilà
eca prévoit là forcément c'est pour ça
que ça a viré au marron garder
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir toutes les images après
on en parlera bien sûr avec alban qui
dit monde et chaleur d'également tension
les esprits sont échauffés à plusieurs
moments de la journée et le travail des
agents de sécurité a été très éprouvant
il combien d'agents de sécurité
acrobates normalement d'habitude on va
aussi en fonction des fréquentations
évidente mais pour ce samedi là on était
à peu près 18 20 agents à oued donc
c'était la folie autour de la piscine
ils sont tous se tenir ils sont pas
autour de la piscine il ya aussi un
amalgame qui est fait entre les maîtres
nageurs d'accord ils font leur travail
pour sauver des biens sur un règlement
et les agents de sécurité qui sont là
pour éviter ce genre de débordements
regardez donc ils peuvent arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc il est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya
une nombreuses vidéos on a même vu un
maître nageur très équipés voilà qui
avait une gazeuse le maître nageur pour
dissiper les gens regarder
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce annoncé attention il
s'agit pas d'un maître nageur régime et
le gabarit 1 pas le genre à prendre ce
risque là non non c'est tout simplement
la sécurité qui intervient au moment où
on voit que ce débordement et est dû
aussi dans un premier temps dus aux
vagues d'accord on est dans un phénomène
de groupe tout simplement c'est un
phénomène qu'on connaît bien c'est un
regroupement de jeunes cons très bien pu
aussi se donner rendez vous pour faire
le buzz en connaît connaître principe et
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
malheureusement les maîtres nageurs sont
là pour sauver des vies les agents
d'entretien les plagistes tous ces gens
là sont là pour faire en sorte que ça se
passe le mieux possible
j'utilise ce terme vu les images et bien
des fois faut simplement que la sécurité
interviennent pour justement calmer les
esprits pour éviter des débordements
encore plus important alors alban
combien de personnes étaient présentes
samedi au sur le en termes de personnel
ou 90 ans de tractations menées sur 7000
entrées sur la journée cette nuit là on
cette ville entrée attention h précises
on est ouvert de 9 heures du matin
jusqu'à 23h minuit en l'occurrence snb
d'accord oui mais c'était dans cette
mine c'est quoi la capacité maximale on
a des capacités qui sont dictées par la
préfecture de police menée l'hiver à
2500 entrées fmi donc c'est la
fréquentation maximum instantané on peut
aller jusqu'à 5000 5 à peu près suite au
comité on a voulu baisser nos
fréquentations maximum instantanée qui
sont réglementaires évidemment et on est
sur du 4000 donc on a aussi prévu ça
parce que très honnêtement et même si je
suis comme vous un les images peuvent
être surprenante en tout cas c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire en tout état de
cause on avait prévu que ça puisse en
tout cas se passer cette vidéo lire ce
qu'on a aucun souci donc c'est 7000
entrées je me mets aussi à la place de
tous les gens qui ont été à ce que
l'aspect un peu paradoxal c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui ont voulu
que rentrée qui on a malheureusement dû
dès midi coupé les entrées payantes ont
donc tout ce qui va être entrées
payantes instantanés on l'a arrêté dès
midi on s'est focalisé sur les billets
datés puisqu'on a aussi des revendeurs
qu'on avait bloqué 24 heures à l'avancé
à 500 par revendeur un sens antique et
c'est pas grand chose pour à l'échelle
d'akobo var cela dit on voit quand même
que c'est compliqué et notamment sur ce
phénomène qui représente un petit peu
attention c'est une image un petit peu
forte mais qui représente tout
simplement la jeunesse qui est là et ils
ne seront pas forcément compte de
l'image qu'elle dégage quoi est là
clairement autant de débordements que ça
je trouve pour nom le monde qui avait je
trouve vraiment eu assez c'est assez tôt
deminor je trouve ça a été plutôt
sympathique bonhomme s'était plutôt bien
géré je trouve que c'est plutôt
sympathique novembre moi j'aurais juste
revenir sur un point puisque c'est vrai
qu'on voit regardez c'est facile de voir
tout ce qui ne marche pas mais c'est
bien aussi de voir ce qui marche ce qui
a marché on s'est organisé il ya eu des
systèmes quand t'es mis en place je vous
expliquais par rapport aux revendre le
ticket on a arrêté la tique et riz à
partir de midi on a mis un système de
barriérage en place on a géré aussi un
afflux assez conséquent de différents
endroits que ce soit paris cimino on
avait aussi un phénomène assez aggravant
où les bases de loisirs ne sont pas
ouvertes en tout cas la partie aquatique
donc on a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
sont déjà large et sait combien le
ticket aquaboulevard au niveau du plein
tarif alors ça va du bon ben si vous
avez des revendeurs on est à 37 euros
l'entrée puis après on a des journées
pas forcément parce que là encore il va
se suicider non pas forcément parce
qu'on est aussi sur beaucoup de prêts
billetterie donc c'est d'ici qu'est ce
qu'on va monsieur en amant six accords
avec des tarifs réduits alors aux
grilles étaient alors vous avez passé
une journée aquaboulevard ce week-end
vous habitez la région parisienne
j'habiterai à livry gargan 20,93
d'accord vous étiez avec qui j'étais
avec ma famille qui votre famille
copains et combien vous étiez on était
quatre 4 d'accord vous avez prié vous
êtes du mois on y va où étaient ils sont
je savais qu'il allait faire chaud des
prévenus a longtemps trois jours avant
ouais donc vous y allez quand vous êtes
avec votre copain et quoi votre frère
quand vous êtes catoki votre beau frère
et sa mère
on va te faire un ami apparemment c'est
la quatrième personne à ce problème
donc vous étiez samedi quand vous
arrivez cette boule dit on va on reste
ou bien vous avez vous achetez vos
billets avant prépayées voilà on avait
acheté nos billets avant donc on a eu de
la chance on n'a pas fait trop de queue
pour rentrer parce que justement on
avait des billets électroniques donc
d'accord face à aller par contre voilà
une fois dedans je pense que les images
résument bien la journée que qu'on a
passé
pour ma part donc moi j'étais en
extérieur on était les uns sur les
autres j'étais allongé j'avais les pieds
d'une dame dans ma tête oui d'accord
avec quand même pas hyper sympathique
ensuite il faut savoir que on peut pas
ramener de la nourriture de l'extérieur
on a le droit d'apporter une bouteille
d'eau et aux fûts de la chaleur je pense
que c'était nécessaire sauf que quand il
fait 38 degrés l'eau en une heure elle
est chaude donc bien évidemment il ya
deux il ya une
restauration sur place sauf que bien
regardez là la queue il ya pour acheter
à boire ouais donc voila quand il fait
38 degrés faire 45 minutes une heure de
queue voire plus pour pouvoir voir je
trouve que il ya un problème quelque
part donc vous avez parlé de deux jauges
on en a discuté aussi en somme moi je
pense que la jauge l'a clairement sais
pas je crois qu'il y à il ya un problème
en fait on est dix ans sur les autres
alors ce quoi il pense vous a dit que
vous avez vécu l'enfer pas en fait déjà
le les bassins il s'est excusé moi le
terme et était dégueulasse quoi on quand
on est plusieurs centaines dans le dans
l'eau l'ol était trouble pour se laver
les pieds certes comme on a dit il ya le
sable mais en soit on se lave les pieds
là pour aller dans l'eau derrière quoi
donc si l'eau est sale lauda piscine
trace à l'oci donc voilà après aussi je
vous avais parlé des agents de sécurité
et là dessus je veux rebondir parce que
oui c'est vrai mais moi j'ai été témoin
de de virulence envers des des jeunes
justement et j'avoue après je veux pas
blâmer ses agents la qui ont essayé de
faire leur travail mieux et je pense
qu'ils ont été surtout débordé par par
les événements mais enfin moi j'arrivais
entendu des propos je me suis dit quoi
vous en donne quoi
c'est ouais si j'étais ton père je
trouvais casser la gueule viens là que
je t'attrape vraiment des trucs mais où
là je veux bien croire que cette voie là
moi je pense que le problème c'est le
monde quoi le monde qui avait il y avait
sur place ont pas réussi à gérer la ce
pour moi ils n'ont pas réussi à gérer la
situation et puis de base on viendra
quoi boulevard pour passer un bon moment
pour que ce serait agréable certes on
savait qu'avec la chaleur il y allait
avoir du monde mais pas autant gilles
j'entends madame et c'est vrai que les
images sont fortes mais moi je voudrais
défendre aquaboulevard pourquoi pour
deux choses d'abord la nourriture
pourquoi alors effectivement c'est aussi
pour vendre leur nourriture mais
pourquoi on interdit aux gens d'amener
c'est parce que sinon un jour comme ça
ce serait infernale il y aurait de la
nourriture dartout des miettes de pain
des sandwichs ce serait impossible et
d'autre part pourquoi il y avait tant de
monde parce qu'à la mairie de paris vous
avez une grève des piscines alors ça
paraît surréaliste qui ont le droit de
faire grève mais depuis plusieurs
week-ends impossible pour les jeunes qui
habitent la banlieue qui sont dans des
cylindres souvent au chaud qui a envie
de frais comme tout le monde ou des
familles impossible d'aller dans les
piscines de paris donc tout le monde va
aquaboulevard c'est plus cher mais au
moins c'est ouvert donc il faut que
cette grève des piscines de parisse est
immédiatement mais on en entend de
cannibales sur la tsr ciani d'algues au
salon mais c'est hallucinant donc du
coup y avait pas mal joué mais c'est
aussi à cause de ça donc je trouve que
vous avez fait tout ce que vous pouviez
faire dans un contexte difficile voilà
je n'interviens on veut et c'est vrai
aussi que moi j'ai je pense un peu au
personnel parce que franchement j'ai eu
des vraies des vrais gens qu'on gérait
vraiment les personnes j'imagine pour
tout le monde qu'on va stigmatiser la
sécurité c'est un peu simple c'est un
peu facile je n'accepte c'est la règle
du jeu
vous avez raison je trouve qu'il a pas
eu trop de la barre de monts franchement
exactement moi j'interviens à dessus
c'est vous savez quand même des gens là
par exemple vos animaux je vais d un
maître nageur qui est dans l'eau citez
moi une piscine qui met les maîtres
nageurs dont nous c'est ce qu'on appelle
les pieds dans l'austère comme un maître
nageur qui est dans l'eau c'est très
difficile de gérer une
type de poules de population qui à ces
jeunes qui viennent pour s'amuser moi
j'aimerais insister là dessus en tout
cas ils se sont amusés ouais c'est vrai
il ya eu des débordements mais un peu
comme partout on avait un petit peu le
phénomène des des artistes ou non on a
eu très peu d'incidents alors accidents
des personnes non pas du tout on n'a pas
eu d'accident et c'est un paradoxe parce
que c'est vrai que nous moi ça fait plus
de 15 ans que je travaille en tout cas
aquaboulevard et dans le milieu des
piscines ça fait plus de vingt ans je
peux vous dire que les accidents
arrivent justement après il ya peu de
monde ah ouais parce qu'il ya un
phénomène un petit peu les gens sont
tous ensemble et il veille les uns sur
les autres si on voit l'image dans le
bassin c'est uniquement une photo ou une
vidéo pris fin des vagues l'ambiance a
été mise les jeunes s'amusent certes à
leur manière je discute pas là dessus on
va pas je trouve qu'ils sont voilà
imaginez deux secondes des maîtres
nageurs qui doivent digérer ça c'est
compliqué donc aujourd'hui on a deux
solutions on les empêche de rentrer
c'est pas juste non plus aujourd'hui on
est dans une logique où aquaboulevard et
quand même représentation d'une mixité
sociale plus que moi j'en ai une cei de
l'intérieur au pied de grue devant je
vous dis la vérité je pense qu'elle peut
être débordements aussi mais je n'ai
jamais changé il y avait donc les
on allait présenter un qui ne convient
pas dans ce genre de problème c'est
simple ça lasse pas mokhtar l'aïe avait
pas d'anglais ya pas eu des bons moments
il ya peu de débordements grave sans
rien au coeur des bons vérité il ya eu
aucun débordement à s'étonner du choix
si fier moi justement de voir tous ces
jeunes qui sont éclatés ils ont rigolé
voilà il ya eu 2 3 c'est normal il ya
2-3 en bout il y en a tout le temps
voilà mais c'est rien de grave mais ça
prouve encore une fois qu'il n'ya pas
d'engrais et ben c'est pas le bordel oui
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
décalage entre les gros titres qu'on a
pu lire dans les médias week end
nautique à l'aquaboulevard violence à la
cua ou pas les images quand on les
regarde en fait oui certes il ya
beaucoup de monde mais il y aurait de
violence iliad anglais n'y a de vrais
fans anglais et des gens qui s'amusent
et tout ça et est exagéré avec les
centaines de messages racistes qui sont
horribles qui a eu sur les jeunes
sociaux sur les chaînes youtube sur les
articles du parisien des commentaires
qui sont à vomir et je suis choqué par
le nombre de ses commentaires et le fait
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit totalement ok de
publier des messages racistes parfois à
visage découvert et que personne ne dit
rien je trouve ça terrible et s'arrête
sur les images techniquement il sera
grand chose et on les dénonce à chaque
fois parce qu on trouve pas ça normal on
née justement cet esprit de loisirs et
de moments de vie
attention il faut se mettre à l'échelle
d'un couloir à coblence et 26 mille
mètres carrés de surface je suis si mon
bras si on ramène à 7000 personnes ça
fait 4 mètres carrés par personne c'est
l'énorme du coc vite je vous le rappelle
donc à ce niveau là quand on dit on est
débordé c'est pourquoi j'en ai déjà joué
je vous dépenses soit au delà de voilà
tout parce que voilà je trouvais déjà
fait travailler énormément de monde et 2
il n'y a pas de discrimination
aquaboulevard moi c'est ça que j'aime et
ça c'est important de rêve je ne vais
pas y a pas de toi tu rentres pas ce que
tu es en famille toi tu rentres pas
parce que vous êtes si john woo trucs et
sa mine de rien et mais qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits je
peux vous dire que s'il avait vu des
bandes de jeunes ça de 6,10 jaune il
aurait dit non on peut pas en écho et
ils ont après y'a peut-être vannes
discrimination cyril une discrimination
au prix ce que 37 euros citi va deux
adultes non mais les environs mais ça te
fait 150 ans elle est la norme et moins
cher si tu te situes tu sais combien tu
seras pas dit
exactement euros 20 euros non mais 20
euros je t'explique c'est un fou car
c'est un patient à forcer face à farina
tu fais une partie de faille si si ça
fait des enfants mais il va de bêtises
oui mais et alors donc c'est un fait
si on est correct l'aquaboulevard
souvenez
50 pour 4 heures qu'on avait un ticket
en restait quatre heures et
même oui mais c'est vous d'accord
mais il ya quand même une histoire sur
37 balais d'imad métissé valser ses
vingt balles ce site où les gens qui
peuvent s est pas mal si tu prends pas
au dernier moment c'est pas mal mais si
tu as envie d'aller à piscine de jours
accord oui bien sûr mais tu trouves
toujours là regardez la météo il ya une
chose que je voulais préciser l'argent
que nous on se justement non réponse se
veut un camion toujours bah oui
maintenant on va pas se mentir bon cette
société
samedi on veut pas payer 17 euros pour
avancer je vais être régulée juste on
revient sur le débat c'est c'est pas
pour réguler c'est les mêmes prix toute
l'année donc y en aura pour réguler le
monde quand
on va être accablé parce qu'on va mettre
à 45 ou 50 euros bon il ya une chose qui
est simple c'est quoi aujourd'hui on
veut accueillir tout le monde attend que
ça on peut rester toute la journée du
matin au soir bien voilà on va payer en
deux périodes bien sûr mais on doit se
payer à manger aussi oui aussi
à limiter le temps de des gens parce
qu'on a vu ces phénomènes aussi qui a
été à l'avant où on a des jambes
d'habitude pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée c'est trois quatre heures
quelqu'un qui vient faire monsieur li
maïs elle restera contrat comme marc
j'adore se parera ya plein jogging 20
euros ça va un roman je trouve que c'est
franchement c'est raisonnable je suis
désolé 20 euros c'est raisonnable voilà
et vous vous avez payé 20 euros voilà
vous étiez vous avez quand vous avez
passé une bonne journée quand même pas
du tout catastrophe en catastrophe je
n'irai pas jusque là mais j'avoue que ça
aurait été plus agréable avec
un problème de taille les piscines qui
sont fermés à vis encore anne hidalgo
rosemont sais pas pourquoi
jusqu'à la régulation sachez une chose
c'est qu'au si on a aussi des demandes
formulées en nous disant il ya un
phénomène canicule s'il vous plaît ne
fermait pas accueillez le maximum bien
sûr mais dans ces cas là pourquoi pas
prendre un peu plus de d'agents de
sécurité par exemple moi quand j'ai
voulu acheter à boire et avec y avait
qu'une caisse doit ça c'est vrai ça
c'est chiant donc pourquoi par nourrir
des prises deux a340 zahia oui bien sûr
mais j'ai d'autres il avoue ça vient je
suis moi aussi donc demain à 12h30 puis
en même temps
j'entame sur les plages qui passe avec
des bouteilles d'eau pour les vendre un
jeu vous en ville et daniel alors
mais pour organiser quand il ya des
situations exceptionnelles parce que là
à faire une queue de trois quarts
d'heure dans le cagnard je veux plus
revenir juste sur une chose on nous
n'avons nous n'avons constaté aucun
incident le seul malaise malheureusement
qu'on a eu c'est en dehors dako
bouilloire c'était une femme qui était
enceinte encore une fois on raconte tout
et n'importe quoi elle a juste et eu un
malaise qu'on en a traité avec un petit
peu d'oxygène un appel pompiers et c'est
tout voilà j'attends donc ce et l'aura
du tout un accouchement mais on n'était
pas bien la situation devait se répéter
autant prendre ça comme une annexe
de pleuvoir existe depuis 89 voilà 1989
33 en galère depuis 33 ans chaque année
chaque expérience et on prendra comme
tel ça nous permet d'améliorer les
choses j'en parlais tout à l'heure les
maîtres nageurs les pieds dans l'eau
suite à des problèmes éthiques avec
notamment des enfants en bas âge qui
sont délaissés de leurs enfants leurs
parents et bien on fait de la prévention
donc là aujourd'hui j'entends le
problème de la restauration il n'y a pas
de souci mais c'est vrai aussi qu'on a
une belle files d'attentes certes un peu
long de la corde mais en tout cas aucune
animosité entre les gens mais parce
qu'on l'a expliqué aux gens il savait le
temps d'attentes on a prévenu on a fait
en sorte d'être le plus présent possible
pour faire de la prévention alors il
s'invite y avait pas que le parc
aquatique d'un cover qui était bondé
samedi d'autres endroits en
ile-de-france qui proposait de la
baignade ont été pris d'assaut c'est le
cas du célèbre lac de cergy qui lui
aussi était bondée de monde regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous aurez remarqué bien sûr que les
gens applaudissent l'arrivée de daniel
movie aussi en seine saint denis
plusieurs jeunes on fait ce qu'on peut
voir à chaque vague de chaleur ils ont
cassé des bornes incendie pour raccorder
au réseau public d'eau potable pour se
rafraîchir regarder
[Applaudissements]
ces anglais ça qu'il voulait dire
exactement cet exemple et on a une
petite surprise au regard des photos qui
fait le tour du web regardez bien cette
photo qui fait le tour du web est-ce que
vous reconnaissez à la voile alors voilà
on va d'abord redémarrer part ça voilà
merci regarder oui ça c'est tout
son importe quoi il en importe quelle
image
léchée regarde faire passer tous moulin
gagne allongé au soleil attendent la
mort par canicule plutôt que de mettre
un orteil aquaboulevard regarder sa
merci s'il faut le retrouver merci quand
vous mettez des tweets vous savez pas le
faire donc ne m'étais pas ça c'est celui
d'après
[Rires]
c'est ça ohlala
je veux voir
de voir les images pour vous des tweets
c'était vrai la france tente de cons
qui sont console à n'importe quoi le
propriétaire et odile bas avec la
canicule regardiez
n'est en tout cas merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci la prochaine fois que vous
irez à la piscine avec daniel elle y va
tous les matins